that's the back story for me that's a
good question i guess there is an
element of speed in both yeah you know
the running up apart so she's she's
kicking in that that you know yeah high
gear you guys remember really cool
runnings that's what i was thinking of
yeah right everybody in the studio
that's right it's a fun movie jamaican
bob's that team right yeah
congratulations to her and
congratulations to us for that morning i
put that in there for you said ted said
morning rain then clearing he's the man
you didn't read that yeah we ignore that
was supposed to read it she refused to
read it ted you're the man hold on let's
go hold on here ready ready hey ted said
morning rain then clearing
he's the man
oh
see we'll just edit that in post you can
just pull the second clip stop trying to
make me cry guys
get a little teary-eyed you are the most
accurate seven years in a row
unbelievable that's why i come in early
and i stay later too sometimes
[Laughter]
outside right now we do have a nice
night tonight winds have calmed down of
course and it was good to see the rain
but i promised you i promised you we'd
show you your rain tallies where we
picked up some good amounts this morning
college 95 1600 some inch henderson
airport 1200 inch the lakes eight
hundredths summerlin four hundredths of
an inch good to see some rainfall again
it was limited to the morning like i
talked about and then it would clear out
later on day and shari and nate and
sally mention that to you 54 in
centennial hills 56 north las vegas 60
even for the east side sunrise manor and
60 whitney ranch 57 mountains edge 53
for anthem 50 right now indian springs
52 boulder city and 55 for
sandy valley it's gonna be another cool
night tonight all that precip is pushed
off towards the east snow in utah right
around zion i'd say and then we've still
got some leftover showers right around
flagstaff
just a ridge in the jet stream we'll
develop even more amplify even higher
than this this week and that'll keep us
clear of any storms however we'll retain
some north breezes i think for tomorrow
nothing too big some of those northern
neighborhoods really starting to feel a
little bit of those winds up tomorrow
and also on thursday stronger though out
towards the lake in the colorado valley
of course but the bigger winds will come
i think on friday and saturday rain
chances after today not been very slim
for anything at all in the 8 day
forecast as well and we really need the
rainfall 43 overnight partly cloudy and
dry a nice evening tomorrow 62 nice and
sunny with temperatures above average
some north breezes temperatures around
the neighborhoods and the low 60s about
64 though for green valley and sunrise
manor will be also nice and mild for
prim at 60 along with boulder city and
69 for lofland here's your 8 day
forecast right around the low 60s and
staying there that goes for next week
too look at a nice looking weekend
despite the wind on friday and saturday
next week we get 60's we really only
have one
hockey game
at home on thursday that's it and then
he did it is that accurate montreal
montreal yeah that's right and then they
head off on the road for a big four game
road trip way back east so
speaking of uh well we're going to talk
raiders
how'd you say speaking of the nights a
little bit